hello everyone and welcome back to the
ftx crypto cup we are in the semi-finals
and
magnus is now facing temura java rajago
had an incredibly difficult match
against tanish geary
uh after the first match which ended by
uh rajab of
winning by a one point margin only one
game was one all the other three were
drawn
uh the second match ended by all four
games being a draw so it was a really
really
intense match but rajava was able to uh
come out on top
uh and now as his price he gets to face
magnus carlsen and then if he beats him
he goes into the finals of the fts
crypto cup
now before we check out the game uh
really sorry about the the previous
thumbnail it was uh
i had something in mind and i was you
know starting to
work on it then a friend came over he
brought some beer and
he texted me that he already opened the
beer and the beer was getting
warm so i really couldn't spend all that
much time
doing the thumbnail as you know no one
enjoys a warm beer
uh but that being said uh really sorry
about that one i know it was a slightly
disturbing it was supposed to be a bit
less disturbing but
uh you know you live you learn uh and
also i would just like to
before we check out the game
congratulate a very happy birthday today
and scott hope you
win many many great games and have an
excellent day but most importantly that
you enjoy chess for
a very very long time now uh that being
said
let's check out the game magnus has the
white pieces uh this is
a very very interesting game so without
further ado let's check it out and also
this is game three the first two games
ended in a draw
uh let's check it out magnus opens with
d4 so all the other games so far magnus
opened with e4 and we've
had so many italian games without magnus
going for the evan's gambit so now
magnus is
going to try d4 we have knight to f6 by
rajabov
and now comes knight to f3 we have g6
and c4 now we have bishop to g7 our job
of going for his famous kings indian
defense and now
g3 magnus uh going for the early fiance
of the light square bishop
uh we have c5 striking in the center
also known as the pterodactyl defense we
have bishop the g2 and
now c captures on the four knight
captures uh and a kingside castle
uh we ignite the c3 and now queen to c7
it's a very nice square for the queen
uh you don't usually worry about any any
knight jump says
this is all been played many many times
so here knight the d5
kind of offering this spawn yeah but not
really because this point is hanging as
well
and it even if it is a pawn trait the
white should be on top after let's say
you trade and then
you can even pick up the bishop brook
captures and now you just let's say
castle
uh and at the end of the day black has
now three pawn islands white has two
white still has the bishop pair so uh
white will
definitely have the upper hand here so
instead after knight to d5 we have
knight
knight captures c captures and now queen
to b6 with a double attack on this
knight
and you can't really retreat to f3
because then the b2 pawn is hanging as
well so magnus defends both threats by
just
moving the knights to b3 and now you
will have to worry about
this b2 pawn for a little bit but like i
said this has all been played before so
both of them know what they're doing we
have d6 and now
magnus just castles and the position has
been reached many times uh one of the
more notable games is dingler and versus
mvl
that game ended in a draw uh try to
bishop the d7 here
also some of the moves that are known
here are nice the a6
also queen to a6 is a known move uh but
here we have um
uh knight to d7 and it is now only as a
movie 11 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how magnus deals with
this
he starts with bishop to e3 it seems a
little bit weird because you still
haven't
developed this pawn but there's a reason
to this you will move the bishop and
then you are going to develop your phone
to e4
but this way everything comes with tempo
so now the queen is under attack
queen a6 and now the immediate bishop to
d4
uh offering a trade of dark square
bishops because in most of these uh
openings the dark square bishop also
known as the dragon
is black's mightiest piece and you want
to exchange it as soon as possible
whereas the light square bishop as well
the title might suggest
isn't really all that uh an impressive
of a piece so here
knights to f6 preventing the exchange
and now rook to e1 now
preparing to push e4 bishop to d7
trying to develop this light square
bishop somewhere it's not easy since the
pawn is really stifling black's position
here
and now of course e4 and now comes
knight to g4 and this is the start of uh
well of a very risky idea rajavov could
simply just continue developing with
rocket to c8
but he tries knight to g4 and now comes
bishop captures on g7 we have king
captures on g7
and now queen to d4 developing the queen
with tempo this comes with
check king to g8 and now h3 all right
this was also the juggles plane he just
wants to shift the knight over to e5
but magnus will not allow the knights to
remain on e5 for very long so here after
knight to e5 we have
f4 chasing the knight away and now
knight to c4 uh if it wasn't for this
knight the c4 jump you would lose this
knight but
the queen on a6 covers the c4 square so
knights to c4 and now comes
e5 so magnus really uh may be
overextending but he does have
uh plans on on what's happening here so
here queen to b6
rajab offers a queen trade and magnus
just improves the position king h2 now
the queen can move if needed
uh we have uh uh rook f the c8
uh continuing development and now rook a
to c1
now our job of trades we have captures
captures and now
uh you have to play something in the
java place bishop to e8 and this bishop
to e8
will really uh be a problematic piece
for the rest of the game as you'll see
uh if for jabba once uh he can simply
grab on b2 and this
can very peacefully unwind into
something like
characters captures and now if let's say
rook captures rook captures
we're going to play rook to b1 attack
the knight and it seems like it's
at the end of the road for black because
the b7 pawn is hanging then the rook
infiltrates the seventh rank
uh however there is this rook to c4 move
i'm only showing this because i know how
much you guys enjoy
sidelines and if rook captures rook
captures we're going to capture on rook
rook captures on b7 but now there are a
lot of moves we can play here
so it's not really not really that
dangerous but all in all they shouldn't
yield
more than a draw for for either side for
example you can even play bishop to f5
here
and now after this uh captures on a7 you
can play rook to d2 now with some ideas
of bishop coming here and
uh well with all of these these threats
in mind
it's not going to be easy for white to
do anything with with the extra pawn
uh but like i said archival went bishop
to e8 and now magnus takes uh
well this opportunity to improve his
position b3
chases away the knight and now after
knight to b6 now we of course
completely uh destroy any of black's
counter play by playing e6
and now if you look at the all of the
squares all of these squares are
unavailable to the to the light square
bishop that is an e8 and this is going
to be a big issue
so here we have f6 uh by the job of
which pretty much helps white because
this pawn chain is now
untouchable for the rest of the game uh
we have g4 by magnus and
rook the c5 now magnus trades here we
have captures captures now okay the
knight has to move
but knight to e2 uh we have knight to c8
now the knight comes to d6 but now rook
to c1
and that's a really big problem for a
java because now the pawn cannot be
defended you cannot play b6 because now
d6 wins the game rook is under attack
once you move the rook d7 and that's it
there there's no
playing this so after rook to c1 arjabo
had to play a
knight d6 but now the c5 pawn is uh
well just gone so rook captures on c5
and now rajab of
uh with uh with the worst position the
bishop is is a no piece uh
and now uh well he's also down upon so
king of
we have king to g3 we have a5 and
now comes knight to c3 so slowly but
surely uh getting more and more pieces
in into the blacks half of the board we
have f5 and here just
g5 not allowing black any opening of the
position
we have b5 and now comes knight back to
e2 now the
knight is coming to d4 and then well uh
anything can happen
we have b4 by tamer and now knight to d4
we have a4 he wants to somehow
make this bishop come alive but uh it's
still not possible king f2
we have a captures a captures and now
rook comes to
a1 uh so what do you do here we have
bishop to f3 now the important thing is
not to blunder any pawns
this pawn is a very well protected uh
the bishop here doesn't allow rook to d1
to kick away the knight and
well you you can never reach this pawn
so it doesn't really matter what the
tamer plays we have rook to a to check
rook to c2 now magnus is very happily
offering a trade here
of course our java declines this and now
we have h4
again slowly but surely improving the
position we have king g7 and now rook to
b2
a bit of a passive square for the rook
but it comes at a price because uh well
you have to activate it this knight and
now the knight can move
uh we have rook to a7 and now magnus
goes for it
knight to c6 now attacking uh the pawn
and the rook so if the rook leaves the
seventh rank then you can just gobble up
the pawn
and if you trade here then magnus now
gets a protected pass pawn on c6 and you
you do not want
this so instead after knight to c6 we
have rook to b7
and the knock comes king to e3 we have
h6 by the job of
now comes rook to a2 so uh
a nice rook lift is coming there's
nothing that java can do to prevent this
captures captures and then now comes
rook to c7
we rook to a8 by magnus and it was in
this position on mu 46 that temura jabu
resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
there is no piece he can move
and there is really nothing to play for
here it's just that bad of a position
the knight cannot move because it guards
the bishop here
the rook really doesn't have any squares
uh if you try and
trade off the rook uh white will happily
accept this for example captures and
captures
and now just bring the king over here
and pick up this pawn there's nothing
you can do about this just king c5 and
that's it you're losing another pawn
and then you're just going to push this
pawn of the board there's there is no
defending this
so after rook to a8 for uh because there
simply is no move you can play here uh
our
job of resign to the game and the game
three now goes to magnus which means
he's now leading the first match and
we'll see what happens in game four
but uh if roger doesn't bounce back he's
gonna have a hard time
uh in the second match but it's not um
nothing you know uh new so this has all
been seen before we
will see sometimes magnus has a really
really bad second match so maybe
rajab can also try and do something
there but here it just felt like
rajabo was trading pieces a bit too much
and then he
got himself into this trap of uh just
having this terrible terrible bishop
here
after uh this uh uh this position here
where he just
retreated with bishop to e8 he could
have gone for this
but uh he couldn't even dream that this
bishop coming to e8 will be the last
square that
this bishop sees for the rest of the
game uh but yeah very interesting stuff
always be very very careful careful with
your light square bishop especially if
you're playing against
some queen spawn opening you do not want
it stuck on c8 or e8 or any eight
for that matter uh but yeah and once
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank fergus duncan lee
roberts daniel
grabowski uh jesse bronson and christian
minds for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing with the coverage of the fdx
crypto cup
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
once again
sorry for the disturbing thumbnail of
the previous video
see you soon